this video is brought to you by full
sail university
[Music]
what's up everybody helen here to tell
you how to survive the end of the world
as an adorable kitten that's right we're
talking about the video game stray which
introduces us to a post-apocalyptic
world where robots have attempted to
rebuild human society after mankind went
extinct but we think there's something
deeper at this game's core that's as
satisfying as finally getting to scratch
a rug because what if a game in which
you pretend to be a cat while hanging
out with robots pretending to be people
could actually teach us a whole lot
about humanity let's explore in this
wisecrack edition on stray do robots
make the best humans but before we get
into it i want to shout out this video
sponsor full sail university full sail
offers associates bachelors and master's
degrees in the fields of technology arts
media and entertainment and they just
launched a new bachelor's degree in game
business and esports which can help
students enter the industry from
different perspectives from game
development to communications and
marketing to competitive gaming itself
and this new major joins a roster of
other cool fields of study like film
production computer animation sports
casting and web development with full
sail university's accelerated coursework
you can finish your degree in about half
the time required at other colleges and
universities plus you can complete your
classes and coursework online or in
person at full sales campus in orlando
depending on what's right for you
whatever model you choose you'll get
hands-on real-world experience in the
career path of your choice plus full
sale accepts new enrollments monthly so
you don't have to build your schedule
around traditional semesters to learn
more about full sail university's new
game business and esports majors or any
of their other degree programs visit
fullsail.edu
wisecrack that's fullsale.edu wisecrack
and now back to the show upon entering
the world of stray we watch our darling
lonesome kitten avatar enter a
post-apocalyptic city humanity we learn
has been killed off by a brutal pandemic
that only their robot companion survived
too soon too soon the gameplay obviously
stands out from the get-go you're
constricted by the ways an actual cat
would move which obviously involves
plenty of jumping and knocking down
boxes the game's been lauded for its
realistic depiction of a cat a feat
corroborated by real-life cat fandom so
by mimicking the abilities and
constraints of inhabiting a cat's body
are we actually learning what it's like
to be a cat according to philosopher
thomas nagle in his paper what is it
like to be a bat nah nagel argues that
most living things have a sense of
consciousness a subjective character of
experience that means that there is
something that it is like to be that
organism something it is like for the
organism but we can never really know
what that consciousness feels like
that's partially due to our limited
imaginations as we inevitably map our
sense of human consciousness onto other
animals but even if we anamorphed into a
bat for a day our brains have been
hardwired since birth for human
consciousness thus we would still not be
experiencing things as a bat nagel
explained but as a person in a bat's
body sure we can simulate cat hood
through adorable video games but because
we haven't lived it from birth we can't
fully understand it but these
limitations actually open up interesting
questions about the robots we meet
because the game positions us from the
cat's perspective it arguably seems to
agree with nagel that there is a
consciousness to be had in cat hood even
if we can't quite comprehend it thus we
can also presuppose the same thing about
the robots they're not human as much as
they try to be but they have their own
kind of consciousness and frame of
reference their own robot hood if you
will but what if anything do robots
share with humans well just as you can't
truly experience a cat's night vision
these robots probably can't understand
the nuances of the human experience
although they have apparently taught
themselves to get crunk but they're
essentially living in a nagel thought
experiment as our robot pal explains the
companions started out personality free
existing solely to perform tasks but
over time they began mimicking humans
and forming societies first we encounter
a village called the slums full of
companions who are portrayed as working
class or lower class folks and there's a
sense of melancholy but not despair it's
an actual community one where they look
out for each other we learned that the
robots posthumously discovered
humanity's art music and society and
this inspired them to try to recreate
the human world fittingly then the slums
despite the grunginess are chock full of
artistic vibes
the robot seemed to appreciate all
things aesthetic
they keep a beautiful tree alive just
for fun and use neon lights just for the
pretty colors musicians play music for
free as long as you deliver new song
pages most of the interactions you have
here are bartering or favor-based if you
collect someone's notebooks they'll do
you a solid and so on this creates a
sense of a pre-industrial society one
where capitalism and commerce haven't
quite established a foothold what we're
seeing are genuine signs of community
encapsulated in the way the elders sit
in silent collective meditation we
learned that momo otherwise considered
an outsider is desperate to recover his
missing friends which demonstrates how
important companionship is for him
[Music]
when you rescue a long-lost scientist
robot he's greeted with love by his son
and former friends everyone is basically
kind to you and even the grouchy sheamus
we learn is only rude because he so
missed his father
what we see is robots interacting
authentically with one another and it
gives them a convincing semblance of
humanity george wilhelm frederick hegel
famously talks about this concept in the
context of recognition which we've
discussed before essentially in order to
understand ourselves as distinct
individuals we need to be recognized as
such by others our personhood is thus
established through affirming
interactions with others who recognize
us as human beings or as the hegel
inspired jean-paul sartre put it the
road of interiority passes through the
other philosopher charles taylor thinks
recognition is a vital human need and
that we need relationships to fulfill
but not define ourselves in this way the
robots through recognizing one another
in affirming interactions are providing
one another an essential aspect of
humanness philosopher axel honeth
contends that recognition is essential
to self-actualization and living freely
this is only possible if you are an
active member of a social community the
cohesion of which has emerged from a
mutually shared value orientation toward
freedom basically you need community to
be a fully formed person now a more
advanced version of robot society exists
in midtown which has a new york or hong
kong feel to it but we aren't in the
slums anymore here arts and crafts are
replaced by commerce and just about
every interaction takes place in that
context and a sense of alienation
permeates this level in contrast to the
slums people in public places mostly
tend to keep to themselves when you do
try to engage many of the robots are
downright rude to you
public culture seems somewhat
superficial the closest thing to
community is the barbershop which is
still after all a commercial space for
the most part these robots seem defined
by their labor rather than by any
semblance of community or by extension
humanity what we see here is what
philosophers call misrecognition or as
honeth explains the withdrawal of social
recognition in the phenomena of
humiliation and disrespect robots are
reduced to their commercial value and
their ability to perform labor rather
than their unique identities or attempts
at humanness taylor argues that when
others misrecognize you it can make you
misrecognize yourself in the lonely
nightclub your companion who used to be
a human points out what's missing he
used to drink with his friends during
the bad times and the joy of these
interactions gave their lives purpose
he sees the lack of recognition as
essential to the apparent unhappiness we
witness in midtown indeed commercial
relations here make for a cutthroat
world we explore an ugly factory where
workers are surveilled by sentinel
robots who also act as police officers
one guy heartlessly gets you arrested
saying
what we see here is that society has
progressed from a pre-industrial system
of favors bartering and small businesses
to a cutthroat corporatized world that
shift is essential to the alienation
that permeates midtown where everyone
seems worried that you're gonna steal
from them the transformation recalls
rousseau's theory about the dangers of
private property he wrote the first man
who having enclosed a piece of ground
but thought himself of saying this is
mine and found people simple enough to
believe him was the real founder of
civil society rousseau believed that
much human suffering could have been
avoided if everybody had told the loser
claiming the land to [ __ ] off because
according to him civil society was a
misguided step away from the state of
nature which is a morally neutral place
where people generally act towards
self-preservation and with compassion
much like what we saw in the slums it's
fitting that in this capitalist
landscape a police state proliferates
via the sentinel robots this mirrors the
real world as historian gary potter
explains the police are primarily there
to protect business property first not
human interactions if that were the case
they would fail miserably this suggests
that a system of capitalism would appear
simultaneously with a system of policing
to enforce that system of private
ownership and when we make it to the
final level the control room we find an
even more alienating environment
everything is antiseptic like a boring
office building the only nature comes in
the form of carefully manicured
centerpieces and the only art is a banal
postcard-like image of a beach the
robots are also completely different
from their downstairs counterparts none
of them have names and they don't do
anything except work silently when you
try to ask them for help they won't even
look at you and just offer vaguely
polite corporate speak whereas other
robots personally engage with you these
robots arguably are participating in
what taylor would call non-recognition
he writes that non-recognition or
misrecognition can inflict harm can be a
form of oppression imprisoning someone
in a false distorted and reduced mode of
being we see that by living in a world
where they're not recognized for
anything other than the work they
perform the robots have been reduced to
the role of well robots and that's in
stark contrast to their more human-like
counterparts on the lower levels
interestingly enough many folks in the
slums dream of making it to the top
where they assume life is better however
your travels from the peaceful community
of the slums to the antiseptic
depersonalization of the control room
suggests they might be wrong the game
seems to argue that progress isn't
always good and the gameplay slowly
reinforces this idea you're able to
converse with just about any robot in
the slums but as you move up you have
fewer options to engage in other words
you are recognized more in the slums
just like the robots themselves the
importance of art to the human
experience is also emphasized by the
game's focus on aesthetics over
expediency it's not about a race to
finish the game it's about enjoying the
artistic experience along the way that's
something the robots and the slums would
know while the robots in the control
room seem incapable of thinking beyond
capitalist efficiency so what can we
learn about our own world from this well
the game seems to be saying that a big
part of what makes the robots and us
more human is our ability to connect
with one another on an emotional and
communal level and as ephemera journal
recalls in the early 20th century german
philosopher walter benjamin lamented
that long-term meaningful and deep human
connections had been supplanted by
short-term isolated moments that began
to constitute human existence so what
was the culprit you guessed it
capitalism as the og karl marx explained
alienation is the objective structure of
experience and activity in capitalist
society capitalist society cannot exist
without it capitalist society in its
very essence requires that people be
placed into such a structure and even
better that they come to believe and
accept that it is natural and just and
that's exactly what we see in stray as
the world becomes more capitalistic the
robots become more alienated from one
another and from you which is wild
because you are so cute their total
absorption into consumption and status
in midtown goes hand in hand with their
lack of socializing or socializing only
in the context of commerce theft and
policing this alienation only escalates
as you make it to the top floor where
you see robots who have been completely
reduced to laborers clearly believing
that their tasks are natural and just
what all this suggests is that progress
under capitalism has a major downside
the breakdown of community we see this
even in midtown where entry into
practically every community space has a
price in contrast to the slums where you
can roam freely what it seems to suggest
is that we become more robotic more
alienated and more detached from one
another when we define ourselves solely
by our ability to perform labor and pay
for things when we fail to foster
communities around mutual recognition we
rob ourselves as something fundamentally
human still this is a largely optimistic
game yes it seems to say that the
efficient world of the control room
where robots indeed act like robots is
bad and yes the control room seems to
mimic aspects of our world where we are
in fact reduced to our ability to
perform labor but what if there's a way
out what if we can still recognize the
aspects of our fundamental humanity your
robot companion does as much when he
essentially destroys himself to override
the system and save all the robots this
suggests that even as our own world
starts to feel like the control room
that there's still hope for us our basic
humanity and need for mutual recognition
can be our saving grace and foster
connection even in the worst of
circumstances and if all else fails you
can go adopt a cat but what do you think
estrella warning about the perils of
late capitalism or are we reading way
too much into a game that your cat could
probably beat you at let us know in the
comments thanks to our patrons for all
your support and don't miss our new
patreon perks and remember you can join
us every thursday for our weekly live
stream hit that subscribe button like
you're pouncing on the laser pointer and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always
thanks for watching later
[Music]